there was a big day yesterday an
incredible day and last night the
Republican Party defied history to
expand our Senate Majority while
significantly beating expectations in
the house for the Midtown and mid-turn
year we did this in spite of a very
dramatic fundraising disadvantage driven
by Democrats wealthy donors and special
interests and very hostile media
coverage to put it mildly the media
coverage set a new record and a new
standard we also had a staggering number
of House retirements so it's a little
tough these receipts that could have
been held pretty easily and we had
newcomers going in and a lot of them
worked very hard but it's very difficult
to when you have that many retirements
we held a large number of campaign
rallies with large large numbers of
people going to everyone to the best of
my knowledge we didn't have a vacant or
an empty seat I'm sure you would have
reported it if you spotted one including
30 rallies in the last 60 days and we
saw the candidates that I supported
achieve tremendous success last night as
an example of the 11 candidates we
campaigned with during the last week
nine one last night this vigorous
campaigning stopped the blue wave that
they talked about I don't know if there
ever was such a thing but could have
been if we didn't do the campaigning
probably there could have been and the
history really will see what a good job
we did in the final couple of weeks in
terms of getting some tremendous people
over the finish line they really are
tremendous people but many of them were
not known but they will be known this
election marks the largest Senate gains
for a president
in a first midterm election since at
least President Kennedy's in 1962 there
have been only four midterm elections
since 1934
in which a president's party has gained
even a single Senate seat as of now we
picked up it looks like three could
before perhaps it could be two but we
picked up a lot and most likely the
number will be three you people probably
know that better than I do at this point
because you've looked at the more recent
numbers 55 is the largest number of
Republican senators in the last 100
years in the last 80 years a sitting
presidents party has only gained a
cumulative total of eight Senate seats
averaging one per decade so if we picked
up two three or four that's a big
percentage of that number so in the last
eight years you think of that only eight
seats in President Obama's first midterm
election he lost six Senate seats
including in the deep blue state of
Massachusetts Republicans captured at
least four Senate seats held by Democrat
incumbents and these are tremendously
talented hard-working people that did
this Indiana North Dakota Florida
Missouri we also won two open Senate
seats in Tennessee I want to
congratulate our great champion who did
such a great job in Tennessee Marsha and
in Utah and Arizona is looking very good
they're really very good she's done a
terrific job that was a tough race and
she's done a fantastic job in each of
these open seats Nemec
recruited very strong candidates with
substantial fundraising and media
support we were getting bombarded with
money on the other side in the House
Republicans dramatically outperformed
historical precedents and overcame a
historic number of retirements the most
House Republican retirements in 88 years
forty-three House Republicans retired
now I will say this that in many cases
they were chairmen of committees and
they left because they weren't chairmen
because the Republicans have a rule for
six years and what that does is
wonderful in one way and lets people
come through the system and become
chairman and another way it drives
people out because when they're a
chairman they don't want to go and not
be a chairman you're the chairman of a
committee and you're a big deal and all
of a sudden you're not doing that
anymore
so they leave we had a lot of them
leaflets I guess you can flip a coin as
to which system is better the Democrats
do the other some of their folks have
been in those committees for a long time
as chairman in 2010 President Obama's
first midterm he lost 63 seats by
contrast as of the most current account
looks like around 27 House seats or
something and we'll figure that out
pretty soon we also had a slew of
historic wins in the governor's races
the governor's races were incredible
against very well-funded talented and
skilled Democrat candidates and people
that worked very very hard respectfully
for those candidates like Oprah Winfrey
who I like I don't know if she likes me
anymore but that's okay
she used to but she worked very hard in
Georgia very very hard and if you look
at him with four governor's races
crucial to 2020 and the presidential
race Florida Iowa Ohio and Georgia the
big ones Florida Iowa Ohio and George
you can't get much more important than
that
they were incredible they were actually
incredible campaigns - incredible as of
right now Republicans will control the
majority of governorships across the
country including three great women who
worked very hard the governors of
Alabama South Dakota and Iowa they
worked very very hard very talented by
expanding our Senate Majority the voters
have also clearly rebuked the Senate
Democrats for their handling of the
Cavanaugh hearings that was a factor I
think may be a very big factor the way
that was handled I think was tremendous
energy was given to the Republican Party
by the way they treated then judge
Cavanaugh now justice Cavanaugh and
expressed their support for confirming
more great Pro Constitution judges
candidates who embraced our message of
low taxes low regulations low crime
strong borders and great judges excelled
last night they excelled they they
really I mean we have a a list of people
that were fantastic and I'm just going
to point him out Mike bossed Rodney
Davis Andy Barr was fantastic I went to
Kentucky I for the most part I didn't
campaign for the house but I did
actually make a special trip for Andy
Barr because he was in a very tough race
in Kentucky and he want
that was a very tough race the polls
were all showing that he was down and
down substantially and he won and that
when I did do Pete's Tauber of Minnesota
great guy he's new and ran a fantastic
race on the other hand you had some that
decided to let's stay away let's stay
away they did very poorly I'm not sure
that I should be happy or sad but I feel
just fine about it
Carlos chabela mike coffman do bad Mike
Mia love I saw me a love she called me
all the time to help her with a hostage
situation being held hostage in
Venezuela but Mia love gave me no love
and she lost too bad
sorry about that Mia and Barbara
Comstock was another one I mean I think
she could have won that race but she
didn't want to have any embrace for that
I don't blame her but she she lost
substantially lost Peter Roskam didn't
want the embrace Eric Paulsen didn't
want the embrace and in New Jersey I
think he could have done well but didn't
work out too good Bob you can I feel
badly because I think that's something
that could have been won that's a race
that could have been won John Faso those
are some of the people that you know
decided for their own reason not to
embrace whether it's me or what we stand
for but what we stand for meant a lot to
most people and we've had tremendous
support and tremendous support of the
Republican Party among the biggest
support in the history of the party I've
actually heard that 93% it's a record
but I won't say that because who knows
but we've had tremendous support America
is booming like never before
doing fantastic we have Larry Kudlow
here and he said the numbers are as good
as he's ever seen numbers at any time
for our country but he's a young man so
yes and see that many numbers where's
Larry you're a young man right Larry and
you haven't been doing this too long but
there's good as you've ever seen and we
may have if you have a question for
Larry we'll do that but I want to send
my
warmest appreciation in regards to
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell we
really worked very well together we have
been working very well together we
actually have a great relationship
people just don't understand that which
is fine and also to perhaps looks like I
would think Speaker Nancy Pelosi and I
give her a lot of credit she works very
hard and she's worked long and hard I
give her a great deal of credit for what
she's done and what she's accomplished
hopefully we can all work together next
year to continue delivering for the
American people including on economic
growth infrastructure trade lowering the
cost of prescription drugs these are
some of the things that the Democrats do
want to work on and I really believe
we'll be able to do that I think we're
going to have a lot a lot of a lot of
reason to do and I will say just as a
matter of business I was there some very
successful people last night we were
watching the returns so if the
Republicans won and let's say we held on
by two or one or three it would have
been very hard out of that many
Republicans to ever even get support
among Republicans because they'll always
be one or two or three people that for a
good reason or for bad reason or for
grandstanding we have that too you've
seen that you've seen that plenty of
grandstanding but for certain reasons
that many people you're always gonna
have a couple that won't do it so that
puts us at a very bad position in other
words had we kept and this is no I'm
saying this for a very basic reason it's
common sense it puts us in a very tough
position we wouldn't buy one or two or
three and you'll have one or two or
three or four or five even come over and
say you know look we're not going to go
along with this we want this this this
and all of a sudden we can't even we
wouldn't even be able to get it in many
cases out of the Republicans hands
before we sent it on to the Senate and
now we have a much
easier path because the Democrats will
come to us with a plan for
infrastructure a plan for healthcare a
plan for whatever they are looking at
and will negotiate then as you know it's
been very hard in the Senate because we
need essentially 10 votes from Democrats
and we don't get those of us because the
Democrats do really stick together well
I don't agree with them on a lot of
policy but I agree with them on sticking
together they stick together great so
now we go into the Senate we don't have
the 10 votes and what happens it doesn't
get passed even if it gets out of the
house it doesn't get passed so under the
new concept of what we're doing I say
come on let me see what you have they
want to do things you know I keep
hearing about investigations fatigue
like from the time almost from the time
I announced I was going to run they've
been giving us this investigation
fatigue it's been a long time they got
nothing zero you know why cuz there is
nothing but they can play that game but
we can play it better because we have a
thing called the United States Senate
and a lot of very questionable things
were done between leaks of classified
information and many other elements that
should not have taken place and all
you're going to do is end up in back and
forth and back and forth and two years
is going to go up and we won't have done
a thing I really think and I really
respected what Nancy said last night
about bipartisanship and getting
together in uniting she used the word
uniting and she is the the
bipartisanship statement which is so
important because that's what we should
be doing so we can look at us they can
look at us now we can look at them and
it'll go back and forth and it'll
probably be very good for me politically
I could see it being extremely good
politically because I think I'm better
at that game than they are actually but
we'll find out I mean you know we'll
find out or we can work together you
can't do them
simultaneously by the way just think of
somebody sewer you can do about no you
can't because if they're doing that
we're not doing the other just so you
understand so we won't be doing that but
now what happens is we send it to the
Senate and we'll get a hundred percent
Democrats support and we'll get some
Republican support and if it's good I
really believe we have Republicans that
will help with the approval process and
they will really help with the approval
process so it really could be a
beautiful bipartisan type of situation
if we won by one or two or three or four
or five that wouldn't happen and the
closer it is the worse it is this way
they'll come to me well negotiate maybe
we'll make a deal maybe we won't that's
possible but we have a lot of things in
common on infrastructure we want to do
something on health care they want to do
something on health care there are a lot
of great things that we can do together
and now we'll send it up and we will
really get we'll get the Democrats and
we'll get the Republicans or some of the
Republicans and I'll make sure that we
send something up that the Republicans
can support and they're going to want to
make sure they send something up that
the Democrats can support so our great
country is booming like never before and
we're thriving on every single level
both in terms of economic and military
strength in terms of development in
terms of GDP we're doing unbelievably I
will tell you our trade deals are coming
along fantastically the u.s. MCA and
South Korea is finished us MCA has
gotten rave reviews we're not going to
lose companies anymore to other
countries they're not going to do that
because they have a tremendous economic
incentive its meaning its prohibitive
for them to do that so it's not going to
be like NAFTA which is one of the worst
deals I've ever seen although we've made
some other pretty bad ones - now is the
time for members of both parties to join
together put partisanship aside and keep
the American
economic miracle going strong it is a
miracle we're doing so well and I've
said it at a lot of rallies some of you
have probably heard us how much you
don't want to hear it again but when
people come to my office presidents
prime ministers they all congratulate me
almost the first thing on what we've
done economically because it is really
amazing and our steel industries back or
aluminum industry is starting to do
really well these are industries that
were dead our miners are working again
we must all work together to protect our
military we have to do that to support
our law-enforcement secure our borders
and advance really great policy
including environmental policy we want
crystal clean water we want beautiful
perfect air Aeryn water has to be
perfect at the same time we don't want
to put ourselves at a disadvantage to
other countries who are very competitive
with us and who don't abide by the rules
at all we don't want to hurt our jobs we
don't want to hurt our factories we
don't want companies leaving we want to
be totally competitive and we are and
right now we have just about the
cleanest air the cleanest water we've
ever had and it's always going to be
that way we insist on it so
environmental is very important to me
and with that I'll take a few questions
if you'd like whoa I didn't know what
happened right go ahead Chuck that was a
lot of hand shooting up so quick there's
a lot to talk about
mr. president you talked to length just
now about bipartisanship the presumed
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi talked
about it last night
I'm sure that's encouraging for the
American people but do you really
believe given what the relationship has
been like between this White House and
the Democratic Party that that will
happen we'll really there's a good
chance yet I think there's a very good
chance if I could just finish it will
happen will you have to compromise on
certain issues to the point where it
could hurt you in 2020 and do you expect
that when the Democrats took over the
chairmanship of all these important
committees you're going to get hit with
a blizzard
of subpoenas on everything from the
Russian investigation come up to your
cell phone use to your tax returns then
you're going to if that happens then
we're gonna do the same thing and
government comes to a halt and I would
blame them because they now are going to
be coming up with policy they're the
majority in the house I expect that they
will come up with some fantastic ideas
that I can support on the environment on
so many different things including
prescription drug prices which we've
made a big dent in already including
some of the things that we're working on
for the vets we've gotten choice
approved we've got a lot of things to
prove but they have some other elements
that we want there are many things we
can get along on without a lot of
trouble that we agree very much with
them and they agree with us I would like
to see bipartisanship I'd like to see
unity and I think we have a very good
chance of sir and maybe not on
everything but I think we have a very
good chance of of seeing that go ahead
one question on the lame duck sir and
one on your cabinet you toyed with the
idea during the campaign of a shutdown
before the midterms in order to secure
border wall funding are you prepared to
go on a shutdown strategy during the
lame-duck since this might be your last
best chance
not necessarily secure that look I speak
to Democrats all the time they agree
that a wall is necessary wall is
necessary and as you know we're building
the world we started but we should build
it at one time not in chunks but you
want much more money and you want the
money to build the wall the whole wall
not pieces of it all over and we are
doing now we have the military now we
have other elements of a wall that are
pretty nasty to be honest with you but
it's nevertheless it's pretty hard to
get through it but no I'd like to see
the wall many of the people that we'll
be dealing with you know in 2006 they
approved the wall essentially it was a
very strong border fence but it was the
same thing and they all approved it they
all agreed I have statements from every
one of them we have them saying we need
the wall I mean they sound like me but
we do need it because we have people
coming and I'm not just talking about
the caravans we have people coming
through our border that you physically
can't put that many people it's a 2,000
mile stretch you can't put that many
people along that stretch to guard it
and even if you did tremendous fighting
would ensue so we need the wall many
Democrats know we need the wall and
we're just gonna have to see what
happens I mean I won't be fighting for
it they have done everything in their
power to make sure where I got the
military 700 billion and 716 billion the
wall is a tiny tiny fraction of the cost
of that but their whole agenda has been
to try not giving me anything for the
wall I really believe politically
they're hurting themselves
I actually think politically that's a
good thing for me but I want to get the
wall up because we need to shut down
scenario I don't know they can't admit
no I can't commit to that but it's
possible and can you give us clarity sir
on your thinking currently now after the
midterms about your Attorney General and
your Deputy Attorney General do they
have long term job security your answer
that at a little bit different time
we're looking at a lot of different
things including cabin I'm very happy
with most of my cabinet we're looking at
different people for different positions
you know it's very common after the
midterms I didn't want to do anything
before the midterms but I will tell you
that for the most part I'm extremely
happy with my cabinet I think Mike
Pompeo has fit in so beautifully he's
done an incredible job at your Interior
Secretary oh we're looking at that and I
want I do want to study whatever is
being said is the interesting he's doing
I think he's doing an excellent job
but we will take a look at that and are
very strong and will probably have an
idea about that in about a week thank
you mr. president thank you
well this is Georgia he gave me a fair
interview the other day so I might as
well ask him a question all right Thank
You mr. president and pick you up there
you told me the other day that you are
an open book so I think I am an open
book so point-blank Democrats go after
your tax returns will you try to block
that or will you allow them now look as
I've told you they're under audit they
have been for a long time they're
extremely complex people wouldn't
understand him
they're done by among the biggest and
best law firms in the country same thing
with the accounting firms the
accountants are a very very large
powerful firm from the standpoint of
respect the highly respected big firm a
great law firm where you would you know
it very well they do these things they
put them in but people don't understand
tax returns now I did do a filing of
over a hundred pages I believe which is
in the offices and when people went and
saw that filing and they saw the
magnitude of it they were very
disappointed and they saw the you know
the details
you'd get far more from that and I guess
we filed that now three times but you
get far more from that that you could
ever get from a tax return but when
you're under audit and I'm on a very
continuous order because there are so
many companies and it is a very big
company far bigger than you would even
understand but it's a it's a great
company but it's big and it's complex
and it's probably feet high it's a very
complex instrument and I think that
people wouldn't understand it but if I
were finished with the audit I would
have an open mind to it I would say that
but I don't want to do it during the
audit and and really no lawyer even from
the other side they say often not always
but when you're under audit you don't
have you don't subject it to that you
get it done and then you release it so
when that happens if that happens I
would certainly have an open mind to it
so that means if the audit is still on
you will not turn over the tax returns
or you lie right now nobody would nobody
turns over a return when it's under
okay yeah go ahead listen when I was
tempted to ask you why you like Oprah so
much but I think I'll go on to the
question that why do I like what kind of
a question is it
yeah just asking just curious but
there's real question media in here the
real question I do like Oprah but I do
she was a person I knew well came to my
place in Palm Beach often and I have a
lot of respect for her unfortunately she
didn't do the trick the real question is
you just set up here and said that from
this podium that it's is your are you
offering in my way or highway scenario
to the Democrats you're saying that if
they start investigating you that you
can play that game and investigate
better than them can you come can I
think I'm analyzed I think I know more
than they know can you caught and part
mentalize that and still continue to
work with them for the benefit of the
rest of the country who are you are all
bets off no if they do that and it just
all it is is a world like posture and so
there enough win it then the follow up
and you heard me it's a good
well since it's Jim I'll let it go okay
I think you miss president challenged
you on on one of the statements that you
made in the talent of the campaign in
midterms there we go that well if you
know modest president that this Caravan
was an invasion as you know I consider
it to be known as president's Caravan
was not an invasion it's a it's a group
of migrants moving up from Central
America towards the border with the u.s.
thank you for Dan why did you why did
you characterize it as such as I
considered an invasion you and I have a
difference if it but do you think that
you demonized immigrants not as electron
now to try want them I want them to come
into the country but they have to come
in Legally you know they have to come
and Jim through a process I want it to
be a process and I want people to come
in and we need the people your campaign
you're clean wait you know why we need
the people because we have hundreds of
companies moving in we need the people
your campaign had an ad showing migrants
climbing over walls it for it but they
weren't act they're not going to be
doing they weren't active
well no it's true do you think they were
actors I they wanted actors they didn't
come from Hollywood these were these
were people this was an actual you know
it happened a few days ago and there are
hundreds of miles away though there are
hundreds and hundreds of more no way
that that's not an evasion honestly I
think you should let me run the country
you run CNN and if you did it well your
ratings let me ask the question mr.
president right if I'm a Russian are you
worried that's enough that's an asked
one of the other folks that said enough
pardon me ma'am mr. president that's
enough this president I had one of these
I may ask on on the Russia investigation
are you concerned that that you may have
not concerned about anything with you
may not investigation because it's a
hoax are you that's enough put down the
mic mr. president are you worried about
indictments coming down in this
investigation mr. president I'll tell
you what CNN should be ashamed of itself
having you working for them you are a
rude terrible person you shouldn't be
working for CNN I think that's a very
rude person the way you treat Sarah
Huckabee is horrible and the way you
treat other people are horrible you
shouldn't treat people that way in
computer go engines defense I've
traveled with them and watch them he's a
diligent reporter big fan of yours
either so I understand to be honest so
let me ask you a question if I can you
repeatedly fart you aren't the best
mr. president you repeatedly over the
course of you just sit down please
well when you when you report fake news
no when you report fake news which CNN
does a lot you are the enemy of the
people go ahead mr. president over the
course over the course of the last
several days of the campaign sir sir at
the end of the campaign you repeatedly
said that Americans need to fear
Democrats you said Democrats would
unleash a wave of violent crime that
endangers families everywhere why are
you could hit very much time
why are you pitting Americans against
one another Seder what are you trying to
be him no let me just tell you very
simple because they're very weak on
crime because they have often suggested
members and people within the Democrat
Party at a high level have suggested
getting rid of ice getting rid of law
enforcement that's
not gonna happen okay we want to be
strong on the borders we want to be
strong on law enforcement and I want to
I want to cherish ice because ice does a
fantastic job the the what they do for
us is so really it's so unrecognized how
good a job they do so we want to take
care of them and we want to hold them
very close because they do a good job
for the question to be clear to be clear
that the quiet very much
why are you sit down for the questions
but you didn't answer my question just
very simply the question is why are you
pitting Americans against one another
sir I'm not that how you view how I'm
citizens of this today what we want a
lot of elections last night we did very
well last night and in many ways thank
you I think it's going to have a very
positive impact I watch NBC this morning
they didn't report it exactly correctly
but that's you know very very that's the
fact with NBC nothing I can do about
that but I want this country to have
protection we want security in our
country I want security Peter
I mean you maybe don't think it's so
important and I think when you don't
have it you are indeed unleashing crime
I feel that instead you would sign an
executive order on birthright
citizenship are you still gonna sign the
executive order on board Berliner you'll
screen that question a little bit later
go ahead okay go ahead sure Thank You
mr. president the investigation by the
special counsel robert muller has been
going on since last spring it's been
over a year a long time that's been over
your head over Republicans head during
the midterms as well is this an
opportunity for You mr. president
to end that investigation would you
consider removing mr. Muller from his
position I could have ended it any time
I wanted I didn't and there was no
collusion there was no anything I didn't
they went after hackers in Moscow I
don't know about that they went after
people with tax problems from years ago
they went after people with loans and
other things nothing to do with my
campaign this is a investigation where
many many millions of dollars has been
spent and there's no collusion it was
supposed to be on collusion
there's no collusion
and I think it's I think it's very bad
for our country I will tell you I think
it's a shame and a poll came out today
by the way from NBC or at least I saw it
on NBC where a majority of the people do
not agree with the Muller investigation
or it wasn't approved they have approval
and disapproval and it had a much higher
disapproval it should end because it's
very bad for our country so if it and
I'm not just talking about the
tremendous expense and the other thing
is they should look at the other side
also they only look at one side they're
not looking all of the things that came
up during this investigation they don't
do that they should also get people that
could be fair not 13 or 14 or 17 I call
them the angry Democrats they are angry
people and it's a very unfair thing for
this country it's a very very forget
about unfair to me it's very bad for our
country so mr. president if it's on guys
to president if it's unfair to the
country and it's costing millions of
dollars why don't you just give him the
mic please I've answered the question go
ahead take the paper well I'll give you
voters I will give you voter suppression
you just have to sit down please sit
down I didn't call you I didn't call you
I didn't call you I'll give you voter
suppression take a look at the CNN polls
how inaccurate they were that's called
voter suppression go ahead please
Thank You mr. president I'm not I'm not
responding I'm responding to excuse me
I'm not responding to you I'm talking to
this gentleman will you please sit down
which excuse me excuse me would you
please sit down please go ahead Thank
You mr. president
now that the now that the House of
Representative media it's so said you
asked me but no you rudely interrupted
him you rudely interrupted him go ahead
Thank You mr. president do your demands
remain to say the same to the United
States Congress on immigration in
exchange for a daca fix in exchange for
an amnesty for 1.7 million are you
willing to change any of those demands
that you gave to Congress earlier I
think we could really do something
having to do with Dakin and what really
happened with Daka we could have done
some pretty good work on Daka but a
judge ruled that Daka was okay had the
judge not ruled that way I think we
would have made a deal once the judge
ruled that way the Democrats didn't want
to talk anymore
so it'll see we'll see how it works out
at the Supreme Court do you still go
ahead go ahead
which group where do you want me to take
your questions go ahead either one
either or both are you together we're
not together mr. president how do you
respond to critics who say that your
message on the campaign towards
minorities have been polarizing I don't
think it has but is the election of two
Muslim women one of them is veiled to
the house which is making history is
this a rebuke of this message do you
think would you say what is it a rebuke
of this message do you think that this
is more reflective of multi-ethnic and
multicultural America that question I
can only say there's you look at the
employment and unemployment numbers for
African Americans for Asian Americans
for Hispanic Americans they're at a
historic high a poll came out recently
where my numbers with Hispanics and with
African Americans are the highest the
best they've ever been that happened
that took place two or three days ago
the poll that I have the best numbers
with African American and Hispanic
American that I've ever had before then
you saw the same poll so I can't say
that I can say this you look at median
income you look at all of the employment
and unemployment numbers they're doing
the best they've ever done and it
reflects it really is very reflective in
the fall yes mr. president I'm from
Brooklyn so you'll understand me
my question is on healthcare how is it
possible to keep premiums down and cover
pre-existing conditions without the
individual mandate to fund it well first
of all what we're doing and we're if you
look at the Department of Labor also
secretary separately separate the
secretary is or what they've done
they've come up with some incredible
health care plans which is causing great
competition and driving the prices right
down but we are getting rid of the
individual mandate because it was very
unfair to a lot of people but at the
same time we're covering the people that
need it but the individual mandate was a
disaster because people that couldn't
necessarily afford it were having to pay
for the privilege of not having to pay
for healthcare and it was bad health
care at that so we are working many
plans Falco we're creating tremendous
competition we had Obamacare repealed
and replaced unfortunately one person
changed his mind at the last moment and
we had no Democrat support I have to say
that we didn't have one vote we would
have repealed it replace it we would
have had a large scale very good health
care plan now we're doing it a different
way we're doing it a different way but
getting rid of the individual mandate is
a very very popular thing and a very
important thing and people very much
appreciate it no no that's that's enough
two questions one I know you went
through the results and you obviously
studied them late last night
what lesson did you learn most from
looking at those results was there one
thing as you kind of reviewed them that
you'll change your strategy not just for
Congress but kind of going for it and
then just to follow well I think the
results that I've learned and maybe
confirmed I think people like me I think
people like the job I'm doing frankly
because if you look at every place I
went to do a rally I couldn't do it with
everybody but and it was very hard to do
it with people in Congress because
there's just too many there will be too
many stops but I did it with the Senate
I did it with Andy Barr as you know
and that he won he won a very tough race
against McGrath I was a very very tough
race in Kentucky and he was down quite a
bit
and I went there and we had a tremendous
very successful some of you were at that
rally and he won that race but I could
only do that so much because there are
just so many players involved but I did
focus on the Senate and we had
tremendous success with the Senate
really tremendous one more quick one
more questions sorry mr. mr. present one
more question oh my I'm so sorry sir
it's rare opportunity a lot of people
are going to be rushing to Iowa rushing
to New Hampshire you know that the
Democrats are already looking at to 2020
do you want to lock down your ticket
right now sir will the vice president be
your running mate in 2020 well I haven't
asked him but I hope so where are you
Mike will you be my running mate
stand up Mike please raise your right
hand now I Mulligan will you thank you
okay good yeah the answer is yes sir
thank you sir that was unexpected but I
feel very fine yeah please
Thank You mr. president going back to
the Russia investigation and potential
investigations from the now
democratically Democratic majority and
Congress some say that you could stop
all this by declared I just I could fire
everybody right now but I don't want to
stop it because politically I don't like
stopping it it's a disgrace it should
have never been started because there
was no crime it is everybody has
conflicts they all have conflicts over
there that are beyond anything that
anybody's ever seen in terms of
conflicts from the fact that people
asked for jobs from the fact that they
have very good friends on the other side
like really good friends like Comey who
by the way lied and leaked and also
leaked classified information nothing
happened there it might perhaps maybe
something's happening that I don't know
about I stay away from it but you know
what I do I let it just go on there
wasting a lot of money but I let it go
on because I don't want to do that but
you're right I could end it right now I
could say that investigation
/ but it's it's really it's a disgrace
frankly and it's an embarrassment to our
country it's an embarrassment to the
people of our country and it's too bad
going what about the declassification of
the documents some say that that would
clear well if you know that there's no
we're looking at verses like
declassification were looking at very
subject more question it's amazing how
people on the other side just don't want
those documents Declassified but no
we're looking at that very carefully I
certainly wanted to wait till after the
midterms can I ask you one more question
mr. president thank you
Thank You mr. president you have
campaigned is a pro-life president you
have defended the rights of unborn
children you now have a divided Congress
it's unlikely past right capacity
pro-life bill toughen how are you gonna
push forward you're pro-life a gingers
gonna push I've been pushing I've done a
very good job - I'm very happy with me
but it's a tough issue for the two sides
there's no question but what are you
gonna do there is great debate what am I
going to I won't be able to explain that
to you because it is an issue that is a
very divisive polarizing issue but there
is a solution I think I have that
solution and nobody else does what we're
going to be we're gonna be working on
that yes go ahead please she took your
place but that's okay mr. president just
a quick question on rural America in
states like Indiana North Dakota folks
turned out for Republican candidates
could you talk a little bit about what
this means for your agenda in terms of
Trade and the farm bill the farm bill is
working really well I mean we could have
had it approved any time but we're
looking to get work rules approved the
farmers want it I'd like it the problem
is the Democrats are not giving us the
ten votes that we need we are everybody
wants it the farmers want it but the
Democrats are not approving the farm
bill with work rules we could have it
very fast with out the work rules but we
want the work rules in and the Democrats
just don't want to vote for that so at
some point they'll have to pay maybe a
price Jeff
thank you very much mr. president you
have you seen any evidence that Russia
or China intervened in yesterday's
election well we're going to make a full
report and unlike the previous
administration we've done a lot of work
on that issue and if you look speak with
the FBI speak with the Department of
Justice speak to Homeland Security we've
spent a lot of time it gets very little
coverage in the papers I mean you cover
the nonsense part but you don't cover
the important that this is very
important and we have been working very
hard on China and Russia and everybody
else looking into our elections or
meddling with their elections but people
tend not to write about it but we have
worked very hard as you probably heard
what do you--what do you intend to say
sir to President Xi and to President
Putin when you meet with them later this
month well have a good relationship with
both I know President Xi better but I
think I have a very good relationship
with both I actually had a very good
meeting in Russia that you people didn't
agree with but that's okay it doesn't
much matter obviously because you know
thinking but the fact is that I had a
very very good meeting a very very good
meeting with President Putin and a lot
was discussed about security about Syria
about Ukraine about the fact that
President Obama allowed a very large
part of Ukraine to be taken and right
now you have submarines of that
particular parcel that we're talking
about yes that was President Putin who
who annexed Crimea so that was President
Obama's regime that was during President
Obama right I was not doing me it was
resident no that was President
annexation oh it was President Obama
that allowed it to happen had nothing to
do with me okay go ahead yeah go ahead
go ahead go ahead
Thank You mr. president
cordelia Lynch Sky News you're a man who
likes to win but last night was not an
absolute victory for you beyond it I'll
be honest I thought it was a I thought
it was a very close to complete victory
when you look at it from the standpoint
of negotiation when you look at it from
the stand
point of deal-making because it's all
about deal-making again if we had the
majority and we had one or two or three
votes to play with
we would never we would have been at a
standstill I really believe that we have
a chance to get along very well with the
Democrats and if that's the case we can
do a tremendous amount of legislation
and get it approved by both parties so I
consider it to be hey look I won Georgia
President Obama campaigned very hard in
Georgia Oprah Winfrey campaigned very
very hard all over the television I said
this is going to be tough I only had me
I didn't have anybody else and I went to
Georgia and we had one of the largest
crowds that anybody here has seen ever
at a political rally and you know what
he won anyone actually by a pretty good
margin he won and then we went to
Florida and they had celebrities all
over the place and a man who happens to
be a very smart person was running Ron
de santis and people didn't give him a
chance and I went and we had we did some
great work and they're gonna have a
great governor of the state of Florida
and then we talked about the Senate and
a lot of money was pouring in for the
Democrat this is a man who's been in
office for like 44 years or something
this a man who's like a professional at
getting elected and being at office so
he's not Bill Nelson not easy to beat
okay and but they had a lot of celebrity
coming out for Nelson they had everybody
coming out for Nelson and Rick Scott won
and I helped him and I think we've done
an amazing job and you could look at
many other places you just take a look
at some of the other places and we just
got the word that in Iowa you have a
governor who just got extended
who's Fanta Kim just got extended and
numerous other places I think it was a
great victory I'll be honest I think it
was a great victory and actually some of
the news this morning was that it was in
fact a great victory but if you look at
it from the standpoint of gridlock
I really believe there's going to be
much
less gridlock because of the way this is
going than any other way damn please go
ahead Thank You mr. president let me ask
you about one of the campaign promises
you made down the stretch which was a
10% tax cut for the middle class you
just talked about gridlock Democrats
they now run the House Ways House Ways
and Means Committee if it means a tax
cut of some kind for the middle class
but that means raising rates elsewhere
corporations on the wealthiest is that a
trade-off that you would be willing to
make well able to enact a memo that this
will have to be now proposed because if
we did it now we don't have the votes in
the Senate you don't have we need we
would need ten Democrat votes who
probably couldn't get them if we could
we could pass it very easily in the
house but there's no reason to waste
time because you don't have the votes in
the Senate but if the as an example if
the Democrats come up with an idea for
tax cuts which I'm a big believer in tax
cuts I would absolutely pursue something
even if it means some adjustment some
adjustment on which side the corporation
to make it possible but I would love to
see a tax cut for the middle class now
that's going to be their decision
they're gonna have to make that decision
as you know if we bring it up to the
Senate we need Democrat votes ten and we
don't have those ten votes and just
because the markets what and just
because the markets would want to know
sir some adjustment would that be one
two three percent on either side - I'm
just saying I would be certainly willing
to do a little bit of an adjustment go
ahead behind thank you thank you one is
you had talked about leaders who had
called to congratulate you did President
Putin called to congratulate you and
will you in fact meet with him at lunch
this coming weekend as I understand it
we're having and I guess a lot of you
going over we're having a lunch for
numerous countries I'll be there I
believe President Putin is going to be
there we don't have anything scheduled I
I don't think we have anything scheduled
in Paris and I'm coming back very
quickly going over there's a great event
this is an important really this is
going to be very important and I think a
very beautiful ceremony I'm looking
forward to going and we're representing
the incredible heroes of the world but
the heroes of our country from World War
one
and so I'll be going there and I am very
proud to go I don't I don't think we
have time set aside for that meeting now
with that being said we're very shortly
meeting again at the g20 where he'll be
there and I'll be there and that's where
we're actually looking forward to me we
will be having we will be having a lunch
but I think there are many people there
did he call you to congratulate you and
if I could also just invite you since
this is a quite a gathering we've got
here to go ahead and talk about the
staff changes that you expect in the
White House while we're here we're eager
to hear about them is generally gonna
stay on as we make changes we'll sit
down and talk to you about it I mean
there's no great secret a lot of a lot
of administration's make changes after
midterms I will say that for the most
part I'm very very happy with this
cabinet we're doing a great about in the
White House sir you've got a lot of
White House staff some have been talking
about leaving general Kelley has been
rumored to be leaving it's a live people
live and is that going to happen people
live I haven't heard about John Kelly
but no people people leave they come in
they're here it's a very exhausting job
although I love doing it I must tell you
but it's exhausting for a lot of people
I'm surprised at a lot of people they
start off they're young people they're
there for two years and they're old by
the time they leave it's quite
exhausting but what I love doing it and
I'll tell you there will be changes
nothing
monumental in that standpoint I don't
think very much different than most
administrations but and we have I mean
we have many people lined up for every
single position any position everybody
wants to work in this White House we are
a hot country this is a hot White House
we are a White House that people want to
work with okay
No No please behind you behind you go
ahead challenging very challenging cases
quite a lot of abuse and a lot of
violence people have died during course
of this campaign is there any way in
which you think the temperature could be
load perhaps peace could break out with
the media perhaps your bipartisan
relationships across the House and
Senate may now produce some change or
we're gonna have more of this a very
fair question look I would love to see
unity and peace and love and then the
other word you want to use and obviously
I think we had to especially at this
particular juncture we had a wait till
after the midterms are over now they're
over if they would cover me fairly which
they don't which they don't I'm not
saying that in a hostile way I get
extremely inaccurate coverage I can do
something that's fantastic and they'll
make it look like not good and and I
don't mind being having bad stories if I
make a mistake cover it I would like you
to cover it fairly but cover it but when
you do something terrific look how
little the economy is talked about a
poll came out this morning talking about
how little the three networks I don't
think they included CNN but how little
the three networks talked about how good
the economy is how little almost not at
all if President Obama had this economy
and by the way if that administration
through somebody else kept going you
would have had negative 4.2 instead of
positive 4.2 percent growth you would
have had negative it was heading down
but here if the point is this excuse me
I would love to see unity including with
the media because I think the media I'd
be honest I think it's a very divisive
thing for our country and you would be
amazed at how smart people are that are
reading your stories and seeing your
stories and watching you'd be amazed how
perceptive and how smart they are
they get it and it really does bring
just you know
I I didn't excuse me you you are not you
are not called on go ahead go ahead
go ahead please Thank You President
Trump
shortly after your victory speech on the
stark night of back in November 2016 I
asked you to what single factor you most
attributed this victory to speak up sure
on the night of your victory I asked you
right after your speech to what you
would attribute your victory you pointed
up to the ceiling and you said that it
was God based off of that how would you
say over the last two years God plays
what kind of a factor he plays in the
day-to-day execution of the office of
the plays a big factor in my life and
God plays a factor in the lives of many
people that I know very well in this
room like your vice president God plays
a very big role in my life and what one
we're back to light a quick one quick
follow which lost last night surprised
you the most and which of these
unsuccessful candidates are you most
likely to consider nothing sir
administration would you but there were
some losses last night and there were
some victories last night that have been
incredible I mean there were victories
last night that nobody would believe
especially based on the suppression
polls they had a lot of suppression
polls
would youwould and there were some
victories last night that were very
surprising but I'm not gonna pick out
special would you consider any it's
tough enough for those people to you
consider any foreign administration Post
moving forward as one of the very few of
the three points that would have
unemployed what would you consider any
of the people who lost last night for a
post in the administration of the near
future I know a couple of very good ones
yeah I would actually go ahead this mr.
president mr. president I asked you on
Monday if there was anything that you
regret in your first two years and you
said that at times you could have been
should have used a quote softer tone
your critics as you can imagine your
skeptics they say they're not holding
their breath on that happening will you
indeed have to change your tone if
you're to get things passed through
Congress after losing the house and you
also said you might extend an olive
branch what would that look like I would
love to have
I'd be very good at a low tone but when
things are done not correctly about you
written about you said about you on
television or wherever it is you have to
defend yourself I would love to do very
very even touch much easier than what I
have to do I have to go around I'm going
around as much easier than facing
somebody and being treated fairly but
when you're not treated fairly you
really have no choice I would love to
have a very even modest boring tone I
would be very honored by that but you
know what when you have to fight all the
time fight because you're being
misrepresented by the media you really
can't do but not about the media sir but
but sir real quickly not about the media
but what about with Congress it's good
it's the present
can you just how you focus on the
economic were your firm please Japan
solutions oh yes sure is happy about
tariffs and his cars go ahead that's my
Chris I exciting so how you focus on the
trade and commerce with Japan who you
ask Japan to the more well who do you
think at all I don't I really don't
understand me how would you focus on
creating your gonna trade with Japan
well we're dealing with Japan right now
on trade
Japan has it's great country you have a
great prime minister who just had a very
successful election he's a very good
friend of mine he's one of the people
I'm closest with and but I tell them all
the time that Japan does not treat the
United States fairly on trade they send
in millions of cars at a very low tax
they don't take our cars and if they do
they have a massive tax on the cars
Japan and I'm not blaming Japan I'm
blaming the people that were in charge
of the United States for allowing that
to happen but as you know we have close
to a hundred billion dollar trade
deficit with Japan and Japan is treated
as very unfairly but don't feel lonely
because you weren't the only one Thank
You mr. president
to international news question the first
one secretary Pompey was talks
about knowing with North Korea have been
postponed what is happening there and
your meetings still happen with we're
going to change it because of trips that
are being made we're gonna make it in
another day but we're very happy how
it's going with North Korea we think
it's going fine we're no rush
we're know her the sanctions are on
you're still expect to be sorry the
sanctions are on the missiles have
stopped the Rockets have stopped the
hostages are home the great heroes have
been coming home Mike Pence was in
Hawaii where the one of the most
beautiful ceremonies that anyone's ever
seen for the fallen disagree heroes very
important when I was running a lot of
people as many years ago as it was in
many cases grandchildren but they were
asking about that they're coming home
and they're being provided to us as we
speak but I'm in no rush I'm in no rush
the sanctions Iran I read a couple of
times and I've seen a few times where
they said he's done so much what if I
then I meant no I'd love to take the
sanctions off but they have to be
responsive to it's just two ways
straight
but we're not in any rush at all there's
no rush whatsoever you know before I got
here they were dealing with this for
over 70 years and I guess on a nuclear
front for 25 years that's a long time
I've been there I probably left
Singapore four or five months ago and we
made more progress in that four or five
months then they've made in 70 years and
nobody else could have done what I've
done but I'll say this I'll say this
very simply we're no rush the sanctions
are on and whenever it is but that
meetings gonna be rescheduled that
meeting but I thought your your meeting
with Kim jong-un sir will it happen in
next month's you sometime next year I
would say sometime early next year
and a quick question under USMC a now
it's been concluded have you repaired
your relationship with Prime Minister
Trudeau yes I have we have a
a good relationship thank you very much
mr. president we've been talking a lot
about division and the division that
exists in this country right now and
some of the statistics are disturbing I
think to just about everyone
anti-semitic incidents have increased by
57 percent since 2016 hate crimes are on
the rise why do you think that is and
what will you do about it it's very sad
to see it I hate to see it and as you
know I've done more in fact if you were
with us the last time we met Prime
Minister Netanyahu said that this
president has done more for Israel than
any other president those words those
exact words
Jerusalem protection working together so
many different things but the big thing
is Jerusalem you know many many
presidents have have said they are going
to build the embassy in Jerusalem never
happened making it the capital of Israel
never happened never happened
but it happened with me and quickly and
not only did it happen we built the
embassy that would have taken another 15
or 20 years and cost probably billions
of dollars and we did it for a tiny
amount of money it's already done it's
open nobody has done more for Israel
than Donald Trump and the nice part is
that's not me saying it that's Prime
Minister Netanyahu but what about the
mr. president what about the divides in
this country mr. president what about
healing the divides in this country what
we want to see we want to see it here
and one of the things I think that can
help heal is the success of our country
we are really successful now we've got
up eleven point seven trillion dollars
in in worth if you know China's come
down tremendously tremendously China
would have superseded us in two years as
an economic power now then not even
close China got rid of their China 25
because I found it very insulting I said
that to them I said China 25 is very
insulting because China 25 means in 2025
they're gonna take over economically
the world I said that's not happening
and we've gone it way up they've gone
down and I don't want them to go down
we'll have a good meeting and we're
gonna see what we can do but I have to
say this billions of dollars will soon
be pouring into our Treasury from taxes
that China is paying for us and if you
speak to mr. pillsbury who probably is
the leading authority on China he was on
the other day saying he has never seen
anything like it
and you know who else hasn't China's mr.
president we're gonna try and make a
deal with China because I want to have
great relationships with President Xi as
I do and also with China you're talking
about that you know how do you see a
role as a moral leader mr. president
just how do you see the role of the
moral go ahead there's so many people
I'm serving as a moral leader though I
think I am a great moral leader and I
love our country go ahead please thank
you you said earlier in this press
conference that Democrats had a choice
that you would not work with them on
legislation if they were investigating
you do you not have a choice in the
matter as well don't you ever grow up
great no no I think it's very
inappropriate we should get along and
get deals done now we can investigate
they look at us we look at them it goes
on for two years then at the end of two
years nothing's done now what's bad for
them is being in the majority I'm just
going to blame them
you understand I'm going to blame them
they're the majority honestly it makes
it much simpler for me they will be
blamed but I think Nancy Pelosi and you
know I put that statement out in social
media today about Nancy Pelosi that if
she's short of votes because frankly I
think she deserves and a lot of people
thought I was being sarcastic or I was
kidding I wasn't I think she deserves it
she's been fighting long for it she's
been fighting I really mean this
there was nothing sarcastic about it or
it was really meant in with very good
intentions I think she deserves it she's
fought long and hard
she's a very capable person and you know
you have other people shooting at or
trying to take over the speakership and
I said if it's appropriate
said if we can and if we will she has a
problem I think I would be able to very
easily supply her the necessary votes
that's not said in any way other than I
really believe she deserves that
position I also believe that Nancy
Pelosi and I can work together and get a
lot of things done along with Mitch and
everybody else that we have to work with
I think we'll get a lot done mr.
president why can't mr. president why
can't you do that well subpoenas are
coming through excuse me why can't you
work together while there are subpoenas
or while there are investigations in
process I think we will look now that
the elections over the election is over
now everybody is in love but then I see
the hostility of questions and then when
I come in here as a nice person wanting
to answer questions and I have people
jumping out of their their seats
screaming questions at me know the
elections over and I'm you know very I
am extraordinarily happy I really am and
by the way I tell you if I wasn't look
at what happened in Florida look at what
happened in Georgia
look at what happened in so many
locations with governorships nobody
talks about the governorship
look at the amount of work that was
given to these other candidates against
my candidate and I mean I'm
extraordinarily happy and if I wasn't
I'd let you know there's nothing wrong I
mean look you look at midterms and you
look at elections elections generally
you see it's very rare that a party who
has the presidency does well we did
unbelievably well to win Florida both
the Senate and the governorship against
two very talented people I'll tell you
what we did incredibly to win Georgia
when you had some of the biggest stars
in the world campaigning endlessly
including President Obama you know I
tell you what this was a great victory
for us and again from a deal-making
standpoint we are all much better off
the way it turned out because I really
believe if that if the Democrats want to
we can do a tremendous amount of great
legislation yes please go should we keep
this going for
yes yes I think you should keep this
doing when you get bored would you
please tell me seriously tell me I don't
want to hopefully not I don't want to
overstay but these please go ahead hi
mr. president
yummy shall sunder with PBS news hour on
the campaign trail you called yourself a
nationalist some people saw that as
embolden white nationalist now people
are also saying such a racist there are
some people that say that now the
Republican Party is seen as supporting
white nationalist love your rhetoric
what do you make of that I don't believe
I just well I don't know why do I have
my highest phone numbers ever with
African Americans why do I have among
the highest poll numbers with African
Americans I mean why do I have my
highest poll numbers that's such a
racist question honestly I mean I know
you have it written down and you're
gonna tell me let me tell you it's a
racist question and mr. president you
know what the word is I love our country
I do you call you have nationalists you
have globalists I also love the world
and I don't want helping the world but
we have to straighten out our country
first we have a lot of problems and
that's excuse me but to say that what
you said is so insulting to me it's a
very terrible thing that you said mr.
president people have talked about you
talk about middle-class tax cuts on the
campaign trail how will you get
Democrats to support that policy you
have to ask them well what's what's your
plan you know my plan is I'll ask them
and if they say yes I'm all for it and
if they say no there's nothing you can
do because you need their votes go ahead
yes Thank You mr. president Francesca
chambers Daily Mail calm you said many
times on the campaign trail that you
didn't want anything Pelosi to be
speaker at least you suggested that you
spend a lot of time talking about her
and I should want I would have so his
let me answer would I preferred winning
by two or three or four I would almost
have to think about that but certainly I
like to win and if I win she's not gonna
be speaker what did she say to you
though yesterday that made you different
her support honestly we had a very warm
conversation you know she loves this
country and she's a very smart woman
she's done a very good job
she was really I mean she's said a very
did she promise her that they wouldn't
think to impeach is that a very very
good we didn't talk about impeaching we
didn't talk about what do you do and you
impeach somebody because he created the
greatest economic success in the history
of our country let's impeach him because
the country is so successful let's
impeach him has he done anything wrong
they ask somebody has he done anything
wrong no but let's impeach him anyway
and they also said let's impeach justice
Cavanaugh let's impeach him and now they
have the second woman coming out that
the first a second and I hate to say
this but it was public and after him
we're going to impeach the vice
president we're gonna one peach Mike
Pence my pinch doesn't get impeached for
anything so let's let's impeach the
president
and then we'll impeach the vice
president these people are sick and you
know what they have to get their
bearings really they have to get their
bearing and when you ask about division
they're the ones that cause the division
they cost tremendous division in the
house regarding all of the retirements
announced mr. president really quickly
you-you-you suggested he was retiring
you said that many of the retirements
that happened in the house made it very
dim in retirement that made it very
difficult for you in this election cycle
and that it was because they were
Chairman's that were chairmanships that
were vacated but Jeff Flake was at a
chairman of a committee and Paul Ryan
also retired the cycle so why do you
think that is whose fault is it that
there was Jeff Sachs cases me pure and
simple
I retired him I'm very proud of it I did
the country a great service go ahead
give him that he is retired I'd like to
call it another word but we're gonna
treat him with great respect
go ahead thank you mr. president it's
like that's another beauty go ahead two
questions please
one one one one to many people it's
alright you seem to enjoy this venue
very much are you going to make the
standard press conference a staple of
the remaining two years or will you have
more briefings with Sarah Sanders you
know when I don't do the I think Sarah's
fantastic where is there where's Sarah
Sarah
so great i think sarah you've
represented me so well and been abused
she's been horribly treated by a lot of
though she's gonna stay on it's very
interesting because sarah was till we're
talking about the other day
so i had appeared where I figured you
know what I'll do I won't do when he
will interview them and then they said
say why is they doing white you know
they're all coming up with okay then
over the last couple of months I decided
I'll do a lot will stop it the
helicopter will do this will do a lot of
and then they say why is he doing so
many press conferences what's wrong what
so when I don't do them you say what's
wrong when I do do them you say what's
wrong and when I go in the middle you
say what's wrong but in the main do you
know that job right okay good
no no you did excuse me well you
complained about access when I purposely
just stayed away from the press for a
while because I wanted to see how it
worked and can I be honest with you it
didn't work well mr. president I did it
didn't work uestion so Sarah will stay
on as press secretary okay please go
ahead
no go ahead first off I personally think
it's very good to have you here because
a free press and this I do two days
actually I do - yes it's vital to talk
earned media it's worth billions go
ahead so I have two questions for you if
that's all right it's a rare opportunity
first just a point of clarification on
the tax returns issue you brought up the
audit that doesn't prevent you from
releasing them I know it oh I didn't say
prevented me I said lawyers will tell
you not to do it
okay what's your next question guys come
on let's go I just thought the more
exciting question than that please
second one Michael Cohen recently said
you call black voters stupid pissed
false Omarosa has accused you of using
the n-word and the Rapala the rapper
Little John has said you called him
Uncle Tom what's your response I don't
know who Little John is I know I really
on the apprentice I don't know oh he was
okay oh I see remarks no I would never
do that and I don't use racist remarks
and you know what if I did you people of
you would have known about it I've been
hearing their tapes for years and years
there are tapes number one I never
worried about it because they never did
I never used racism I've never used
racist remarks okay well one you
no no one point of that is a quiet among
like in America it's just 8% sir single
digits see when you talk about division
it's people like this that cause
division great division great no now
point of fact is that I never used a
racist remark that's the point of fact
we're who you from Yahoo Yahoo you good
good I hope that I hope they're doing
well were you from yes Thank You mr.
president
we're so happy to be as well have this
opportunity mr. president Erdogan said
he's not gonna follow your sanctions and
he's gonna keep buying oil from each
other a president erdogan Turkey I know
I know and you're gonna meet him soon
just can't understand this okay you're
gonna meet him soon you're gonna have
this talk and some countries are gonna
take the same steps that President or
the guys doing so let me just say about
the oil okay so what we imposed just
recently the strongest sanctions in the
history of our country just about oh I
guess North Korea's there too but I gave
some countries a break on the oil I did
it a little bit because they really
asked for some help but I really did it
because I don't want to drive oil prices
up to $100 a barrel or 150 dollars a
barrel because I'm driving them down if
you look at oil prices they've come down
very substantially over the last couple
of months that's because of me because
you have a monopoly called OPEC and I
don't like wait and I don't like that
monopoly I don't like it and oil prices
are coming down so rather than deciding
to be as tough as I am on most of the
sanctions what I've done is I said we're
not going to do it that way we're gonna
let some of the oil go out to these
countries that really do need it because
I don't want to drive the oil prices up
to 100 or 150 dollars which could happen
very easily it's a very fragile market
very very fragile I know it very well
and it's the absolute right decision and
they'll get tougher as time goes by
maybe but I don't want to have any
effect on the oil prices worldwide where
I Drive them up
because I consider that to be a tax and
I don't like taxes have a peace process
Palestine please the peace process is
over whoo Oh congratulations to Jon
Tester congratulations I'm sure you're
very unhappy about that go ahead yes can
you address that we'll take a couple of
more and then we'll go can you address
concerns in places like Georgia where
people waited in line to vote for hours
where voting machines weren't working in
certain districts and I think that's the
reason that the candidate lost what
there are concerns being raised that
that the United States are you concerned
about the access that people are having
to voting I heard it was very efficient
in Georgia I heard it was very efficient
but again you'd have to ask the state
governments because just one of those
things you're gonna have to ask them
yeah go ahead please please go ahead
thank you Thank You mr. president
you expressed some concerns about social
media companies unfairly censoring
conservatives during the election
do you anticipate working with Democrats
to regulate these companies or are you
sad I would do that yeah I would look at
that verse I think it's a serious
problem at the same time you start
getting into speech it's a very
dangerous problem that could be the
beginning so it's very dangerous believe
it or not I'm one that really likes free
speech a lot of people don't understand
that but I am a big believer when you
start regulating a lot of bad things can
happen but I would certainly talk to the
Democrats if they want to do that and I
think they do want to do that yes sir
former president former President Barack
Obama famously said that he had a pen
and a phone to use executive power on
issues like immigration do you see
yourself using executive power to get
some of your immigration agenda done I
do I do I think that some of it I can
use executive power on some not all well
I I mean he certainly used it he used it
on daca and when he did it he said
something to the if
that I'm not allowed to do this it'll
never hold up but I'm doing it anyway
and he did it and they found judges that
approved that we also found judges that
didn't approve it so it's obviously
gonna be determined in the Supreme Court
and if this if the court rules in favor
of what President Obama thinks they
should rule which is what he said then I
will probably have a deal with the
Democrats in a very short period of time
we were very close to having a deal
until we got that very strange ruling
some promises about immigration during
the campaign I want to know if you're
gonna follow through with them are you
gonna regress one of your talkative
birthright citizenship are you gonna
sign an executive order today are
looking at it very seriously absolutely
yes or no right go I believe we have the
absolute right but that's another case
that will be determined by the Supreme
Court of the United States are you to
send 15,000 troops to the border you've
been reading the same documents as I
have you know exactly what I'm doing you
know exactly what I'm doing
so what's your next question also under
the khashoggi matter more than a month
since the death of mr. Khashoggi a
journalist who said thank very terrible
thing do you think Saudi Arabia is
guilty of of having you murdered and if
so in on that subject over the next week
and I'm working very closely with
Congress we're working together some
very talented people and we're working
with Congress we're working with Turkey
and we're working with Saudi Arabia and
I'm forming a very strong opinion go
ahead John go ahead John mr. president
just a quick fault you said something
about Nancy Pelosi you said the Nancy
Pelosi she loves our country do you
regret some of the things you said
during the campaign I mean arias times
you said Democrats want to put a
wrecking ball to our future I believe my
country live that with their current
policy they are using a wrecking ball in
our country I believe that 100% this
would be a wrecking ball but I think
there's a compromise somewhere and I
think that could be really good for our
country okay how about one more get the
add that you did that was branded as a
racist Adam even thought it was wouldn't
air and NBC would never works
yeah surprise you asked me that question
I do not go ahead please son thank you
sir and I think we'd all love to have
more of these if you're willing in 2017
shortly after you took office your
Homeland Security Department shuddered a
program to counter homegrown right-wing
extremism white supremacism and related
terrorist groups domestic terrorist
groups and redirected that funding
towards fighting Islamic terrorism do
you believe that white supremacist
terrorists right-wing terrorists these
homegrown terrorists on that side of the
spectrum are a problem sir and yeah what
is your administration
I believe all hate is a problem but I do
believe that is a problem and it's a
problem we want to solve okay what are
you going to do about it sir
sir what are you going to do about it
cut off the funding
mr. president you know given funding for
that a lot of funny but I do believe
it's a problem and and can I tell you
what it's a problem that I don't like
even a little bit go ahead I Iike Diaz
with Hearst television you've said
pretend I'm on the ballot yesterday you
called it a referendum on your
presidency many local districts across
the country rejected your midterm
message particularly suburban women how
do you bridge that divide now also with
the images very well received I mean
just look at the results midterm
elections are disasters for sitting
presidents and administration's this has
been a very successful and and look you
can write it any way you want and if you
disagree with me this has been an
incredibly successful you look at the
races how about Ohio I didn't even
mention I mentioned Florida I mentioned
Georgia how about the Governor of Ohio
the fantastic voters excuse me a
fantastic man who was down in the polls
and everybody was talking about this
person that was so great and I went up
there and I did a rally and they have
now a great governor you're going to
have a great governor in Ohio for
hopefully a long period of time but for
four years
and Mike DeWine is a fantastic person
and I went up there for two reasons
because I felt that his opposition was
not a good person and we know a lot
about him and I felt that Mike was a
fantastic person and he won and not only
did he win he won easily so add that to
Florida and aired that to Georgia and in
that to all of the other races that we
won outside even of the Senate races
which were the biggest of all because
these were races that and Mike Pence can
tell you and some of the folks over here
could tell you these were races that
were going to be unopposed we were going
to we were not going to oppose certain
of the people running certain senators
they said they couldn't be beaten
they said Heidi could not be beat please
don't do it thinking this was a year out
telling me about you telling me about
popularity they said many of these
people when I said nine out of eleven
but I said when many of these people
these weren't like easy race these were
tough races and so I think the level of
popularity with the first question I was
asked was about well what have you
learned what about your own popularity I
think that's what I learned is my PI I
was very well received by this great
country by the people of our great
country and I'm very proud of it because
I love the people of this country these
people we are the greatest people I love
the people of our country I'm winning
and I'll tell you something when you
look at the races that we won in Florida
which we weren't expected to win and
Georgia which we weren't expected to win
and Ohio which we weren't expected to
win and won I mean you look at some of
them the number of votes that we got is
incredible so I'm really happy with not
only the way it came out but the
response to me as your president and as
your president I've made our country
safe I've rebuilt and ever in the
process of rebuilding our military and
the jobs are here every one of them
built here we're gonna have the strong a
very shortly we're gonna have the
strongest military our country has ever
had
I've done more for the vets than any
president has done certainly in many
many decades with choice and with other
things as you know with other things but
our vets are doing better than they've
ever done but if you look at choice
choice alone I mean just take a look at
what we've done with choice but the
people of our country are very happy
with the job that I'm doing and you know
one of the things one of the things one
of the things that they want so much is
security they want security both at the
border they want it with our military
they want it with law enforcement they
want it with ice you know we've taken
out thousands of ms-13 gang members
thousands out of hard to believe
thousands out of our country women of
our country who are incredible people
they want security they want safety they
want financial security also we've done
that but they want physical security and
we've taken out thousands of people that
shouldn't be in this country but we have
to get strong immigration laws so they
don't come in we want laws where they
don't come in well we don't have to take
them out per se and again I'm very
honored to be with all of you it was a
great day yesterday it was a great
evening I think we had a tremendous
success and hopefully the tone can get
better
hopefully that hopefully the tone can
get a lot better and I really believe it
begins with the media I really we used
to call it the press mr. president I
really believe it begins with the media
if you would cover and it was a very
interesting story written in a very good
paper recently that talked about the
fact that it isn't good what the media
is doing and that I do have the right to
fight back because I'm treated very
unfairly so I do fight back and I'm
fighting back not for me I'm fighting
back for the people of this country
thank you all very much
thank you
well there we are that was a press
conference by Donald Trump and it lasted
for about an hour and a half and once
again was quite extraordinary